Speaker 1: Let's go back to the phones. And
by phones I mean discord. We're using digital
phones at this point. David Pakman dot com
slash discord is the place to go. Let's go to
Ty from Connecticut. Ty, what is going on?
Speaker 2: Hey, David. I just wanted to.
Kind of give my $0.02 on like I think it was
a re-upload you. About Obama like comments
that he had about the too far left in the woke
left and this and that. And I just I really.
I really struggled with that one because in
my opinion, I think Obama is probably more.
Responsible, you said.
Speaker 1: I'm still here. Yeah.
Speaker 2: It's probably more responsible
for I think. I think the disillusionment
of a lot of activists and maybe the rise of
wokeism than I mean, any other phenomenon I
can think of. Certainly that was how I was
affected. Being disappointed by the lack of.
Progressive ideals and policy makers. Whole Avenue
was written in by Citigroup. He bailed out. Banks
and not the homeowners. He continued torture. He
I think I think more than anything, any single
policy issue that really drives me insane is
that I think that he is somewhat responsible for
the rise of Trump. I think that here's.
Speaker 1: The here's why I struggle.
Let's just pick one thing, because you're
mentioning you're mentioning a lot and
I don't know if a question is coming. So
let me just comment on one aspect of that.
Speaker 2: It's not really it's not really
a question. It's not if it's being discrete.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So listen, I mean, here's the
thing. The entire like Obama led to Trump sort of
thing. The reason I find that to be really tough
is one perspective is Obama led to Trump by not
being as progressive as he pretended he was going
to be. Which disillusion people, which caused
some people to say, I'm not going out to vote
for Hillary, so let it be Trump, if that's the
alternative. Okay, so that's one perspective. The
other perspective is Obama, by being half black,
allowed Trump to coalesce nativist xenophobes,
starting with the birth certificate thing,
moving in to the Mexican rapists thing. And so,
like, that's a different way in which you could
say Obama led to Trump, but it's just Obama's
identity. It's nothing he can control. So I don't
know. I think there's a mix of stuff that went on.
Speaker 2: Can I just add one little quick thing
to that very last point? Because I wanted to
touch on that, though. Sure is not. I find him.
Responsible for a lot of that because in in the
face of that that. Virulent gross racism that
was festering and targeted at him. I mean, the
reason why Donald Trump even became a popular
political figure in this modern era was because
he was on Fox News every other month talking
about how Obama was wasn't a American because
he was black. Yep. And and. Oh, and here's my
frustration with kind of like where you're going
with Obama saying is we that was the moment we
needed to wokeism. That was the moment that we
needed him to call that a spade a spade and not
play around with it and joke with it like it was
something funny. And to bring attention to it
and to have the political, historical foresight
and retrospective to understand what it is that
you're placating instead of having beer summit
with police who murder innocent black people.
Speaker 1: And yeah, I don't. I don't. I think
I get what you're going. I don't know that my
view on it is so black and white. I think you
can have the beer summit to send one signal and
then you can take seriously the birth certificate
thing and then you can joke about it at the White
House Correspondents Dinner. I don't know to
say those are the reasons that I struggle with
that. But let me give it some more thought. I'm
glad you've had your opportunity to to make your
point. And I hope to hear from you again.
Speaker 2: Okay. Thank you. Take care.
Speaker 1: And just as a reminder, please get
right to your question, because we do have a
lot of people that want to get on. And I think
as a general thing, people will be appreciative
of that and that's an important thing. Let's go
to Steve from the San Francisco Bay area. Steve,
welcome to the program. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hey, Jim, cool to talk to you again.
Thank you. I agree with Jill about the JB stickers
on the Christian cars. Like I'm a Christian,
you know that. And that's just not
cool. Anyways, on my question. Yep.
So I was talking to a coworker the other day about
like how much money would it take for you to just
quit your job, retire and just pursue whatever you
wanted to pursue and have to like work for money?
Like my, my number would be like 5 to 10 million,
I guess, but that's arbitrary for each person. Why
would you don't have to share what your number
would be about? What would you do if like money
wasn't a factor for you? Would you continue
doing this show? Would you do something else?
Speaker 1: Yeah, I'm doing it now. I mean,
that's the amazing. I'm doing what I want to
be doing. And it's great that it's worked out
to be, you know, a business that functions. But
I'm doing the thing I want to be doing.
Speaker 2: That's great. Yeah. It's not
just money. That's pretty.
Speaker 1: Sweet. I mean,
I guess maybe I'd consider going in,
like, selling athletic shoes or something
like that, but I kind of like what I'm doing.
Speaker 2: Cool. What do you do in your free time
for a hobby? Hobbies and just personal growth.
Speaker 1: This is quite a call I read. I travel.
I go to the gym, I bike and run. You know, I hang
out with my baby daughter, which takes up a lot
of time. A lot, a lot of time. If you want to if
you want to figure out, you know, how to really
optimize your time, have a have a baby around.
What else? What are my other hobbies? I don't
know. Making prank phone calls to other political
shows. Oh, damn. I'm not supposed to say that.
No, I don't know. I mean, you know,
it's OP. It's all pretty basic.
Speaker 2: Cole I just wanted to ask
an atypical question more about your
personal opinions on some nonpolitical things.
So that's all then. Thanks for taking my call.
Speaker 1: What show are you watching right now?
Speaker 2: Well, I'm not watching anything.
I'm just waiting in the lobby,
getting ready to go to work.
Speaker 1: No, I don't mean literally
right now. I'm saying, is there a TV
show right now that you're watching?
Speaker 2: Oh, I'm sorry. I mean,
a show. I'm I mean, I'm a there's a lot out there.
I'm I really was in the rings of power while
that was on, and I binged the crap out of that.
Speaker 1: I haven't heard of that. All right.
All right. Well, thank you for the call.
Speaker 2: Appreciate it. Oh,
thanks, man. All right.
Speaker 1: There we go. I'll
have to check. I have to check out that show.
It sounds sounds compelling to some degree.